大家好，这里是马尔克斯的朋友。我是圆圆。
本期节目由中国家用服务机器人品牌。
连续11年中国销量第一的科沃斯赞助播出。
今天我们聊的主题是。
思考外包饭了，我们应该如何培养独立思考能力。
这是一个稍微有一点大的话题，
但是我却认为它有一点点的紧迫。
怎么说呢，就是最近我发现我的一个生活习惯变了。
就是以前我脑子里面很容易蹦出一些奇奇怪怪的问题。
这些问题都不是很好回答的，
所以我经常会找一个时间去好好地思考，
试着给出一些答案。
但是我发现我现在不这样做了，
我现在只要脑子里面出现一些有趣的问题，值得思考的问题。
那么接下来我就会掏出手机，打开小红书或者AI，
去问关于这个问题的答案，
可能会有非常多的答案。
但是这些答案由于它不是我们思考出来的。
当下看到答案我可能会觉得哦有道理，
但是一旦我关上手机我就完全忘记了这个问题的答案是什么。
好像确实是这样，
一个问题如果你不是经过自己的思考才得到它的答案的，
那么你会对它几乎没有什么记忆。
如果没有这个思考过程的话，你很难记住这个答案。
我们小时候做作业，
老师都会说你先把这个题做完了，
做完了之后你再去看参考答案。
如果你直接把答案抄上去，
那么这个作业对你来说它其实是完全无效的，
你没有经过联系，
你没有让这些知识和信息真正停留在你的大脑里。
并且我发现我还不是孤立，
我现在很多朋友也是很习惯于将思考外包，
大家知道了一个问题，提出了一个问题之后，
非常急迫的想知道答案。
最好这个答案还有实际的行动可以操作一二三你要怎么做。
看上去我们效率变高了，
看上去我们很容易找到自己想要的答案。
但是我们也发现在这个过程中，
我们的思考本身不知道去哪了。
那么今天这期节目，
我就想跟大家聊一聊我们的思考是什么样的，
以及我们又应该如何培养独立思考能力。
我个人有一个经验就是，
如果你善于思考，你会思考，
你有深度思考的能力，你有独立思考的能力，
那么你的情绪问题会大大减少，
甚至在一定程度上的缓解你的焦虑和意义情绪。
如果你不擅长思考的话，
它很有可能加重这种负面情绪。
我可以给大家举一个例子，
很多时候愤怒这个情绪有可能是假的。
我不是说你正在愤怒出现的这个愤怒是假的，
而是你为何产生愤怒是假的。
有很多时候我们的愤怒不是由于这件事情真实是什么样才愤怒的，
而是由于你错误的理解错误的揣测，
或者是你知道的素材不够多产生的这种情绪。
最常见的就是我们经常看电视剧嘛，
电视剧里面男主女主因为某些误会，
愤怒、难过，然后两个人只是伤心欲绝地离去。
有时候我们看得很着急啊就会想，
他们两个是没有长嘴吗？
其实实际上是两个人没有长脑子。
哎呦我这话说的有点难听，没有运用脑子。
如果这个时候人能静下来去理性思考的话，
会发现他还有很多种可能。
他有可能是你误会的这种情况，
他也有可能是另外一种情况，
但是因为没有去过多的去理性的去想，
他有几种情况出现导致会有这种痛苦啊纠结啊。
但是呢，因为我们是上帝视角，
你作为观众你能知道他们两个是因为误会，
只是我们在生活中我们是没有一个上帝视角的，
所以我们也不知道真实情况是什么样。
当我们被情绪全部占领的时候，
我们也是没有办法理性去思考。
电影中也经常会有这种叙事技巧叫做叙述性诡计，
也就是说，
导演他可能故意把你引向某种情结的可能，
最后他一翻转发现不是这样，
观众恍然大悟。
这几年我看到一个类似于这种叙述方法的电影，
就是《世之玉河》的怪物。
这是一个非常有意思的电影，
我就不剧透了，
但是我可以说一下我在观影的过程中是什么样的心情，
首先前15分钟我是极其愤怒的。
再接下来我变得非常疑惑，
然后再接下来我变得非常揪心，
最后的最后我的内心充满了阳光，
觉得这是一个非常温暖的故事。
因为他这个电影其实是拍的某一个世界，
然后这个世界是用不同的视角去看待的，
所以他就会有不同的心情。
我就不剧透了，
大家感兴趣的话可以去看一下。
我想要说的就是，
如果你有一个独立思考的能力，
如果你能充分地理解现实是什么样的，
此刻正在发生什么样的事情，
你有足够的推理能力，
你有足够的逻辑力去认知这个世界，
那么你的焦虑啊，
愤怒啊，
由于你对这个世界有误解而造成的一些非常不好的情绪，
会得到极大的环节。
除此之外，
我觉得能够独立思考的人他一定是自由且幸福的。
首先他对自己的所有思考是负责任的，
因为他知道这是我的思考，
我有能力承担这件事情，
所以我这样做了，
他就没有抱怨的人了，
他就坦坦当当地生活下去了。
如果一个人他没有独立思考能力，
所有的事情都跟风或者是别人说了算，
那么如果他的生活有哪怕一点不如意，
他就很容易甩锅给别人，
他很容易觉得我不承担我自己的责任，
是因为别人，
所以独立思考对我们来说一定是重要的。
但是呢，
如果你很喜欢思考吗？
我们也会经常遇见一个问题，
就是思考这个东西到底是什么呢？
有时候我们会说我们在思考，
有时候别人会说我们想太多，
所以我们在聊独立思考的时候，
我们就一定要区分一下，
什么叫思考，
什么叫做想得太多。
只要一个人他的大脑在运动，
那么他就是在思考吗？
这是一个问题，
我在想这个问题的时候，
我在想，
那我不可以去网上产，
我要自己用来想对我来说，
思考和想太多，
到底他俩的区别是什么？
然后当我想完之后有了一个答案，
我跟我朋友在聊天，
我也问他，
我说,
你觉得思考和想太多之间有什么区别？
因为他以为我有的答案，
我接下来要告诉他吗？
然后他说是什么？
就在那问我，
然后我说，
你自己想一下，
你先给出一个你的答案，
这个时候他才开始思考，
其实每个人他都有思考能力的，
就是你愿不愿意去触发这个思考，
在现实生活中，
我们太容易把思考划过去了，
所以在我接下来说出我想出来的答案之前，
正在听播客的大家也可以去思考一下，
思考和想太多，
究竟有什么区别？
大家也可以暂停一下去想个几分钟，
那么接下来我要说我自己想出来的答案，
对我来说，
思考它通常是前进的，
它从一个点到另外一个点，
它由于一个问题，
它有一个起点，
它一步一步是有一个清晰的逻辑的，
它有在前进，
它有在想办法解决，
它想办法釐清，
它想办法把这些事情，
从宏观，从微观，
从任何一个理性的角度去履顺，
它梳理，
它前进，
但是想太多，
通常它就是来回的，
倒腾，来回的想，
翻来覆去的想，
一句话可能想很多遍，
一个感受可能要不停地反出，
它不是一个前进的状态，
它是一个停滞的状态，
就比如说你前一天和朋友聊完天，
你回来之后，
你一直不停地想，
哎呀我那句话说错了，
是不是不太好呀，
它怎么看我呀，
来回的这样想，
它是没有前进的方向的，
它也没有解决方案，
如果你是一个思考的人，
你可能就会有一个清晰的思维流程，
比如说你的朋友是一个什么样的人，
他会建议你这样说吗，
他是一个包容的人吗，
如果他是一个包容的人，
那么你就不用去反复地觉得自己话是不是说错了，
如果他是一个不包容的人，
你觉得你自己的话，
当时可能冒犯了他或者有什么不对的地方，
你也可以跟他说清楚，
所以你能感觉到他就是一个向前推进的过程，
想太多呢，
那就是一个毛线团越理越乱，
他就不是一个梳理的清晰的过程，
他只会让你更焦虑，
更难过，
更不舒服，
所以思考本身他是带来清晰的，
他是带来稳定的，
他会缓解很多你的焦虑，
如果你不太会思考的话，
你只是想太多，
那么你的情绪问题可能会变得越来越严重。
刚才我让大家也去想一下，
思考和想太多之间有什么区别，
我不知道大家的答案是否跟我的很像，
如果你有不一样的答案也可以写在评论区，
我们共同探讨，
你可能会带来很多很新鲜的视角，
有没有发现人的思维还是挺有趣的，
前一段时间我也发现一件事情就是，
大家有没有觉得很多这一代年轻人，
他可能已经30多岁了，
但是他身上还有一种比较幼稚的感觉，
好像你也不太会把他当成大人，
他身上有一种很强烈的未成熟感，
可是我们爸妈那一代的人，
感觉十几岁的时候，
他们就已经是一个大人了，
已经被当成一个大人看待了，
所以我就在想是不是因为，
他们十几岁的时候，
他们已经开始自己做决定，
通过思考做决定了，
他们已经会承担责任，
但是我们现在可能30多岁的时候，
我们对自己的每个决定，
排都是悠悠欲欲，
就会觉得哎我真的可以做决定吗？
他就会导致整个人处在一种不那么成熟的状态，
因为人成熟不是因为你年龄增长才成熟的，
你不会因为年龄增长，
他就自然成熟，
而是你开始承担责任，
你开始有自己的思想，
你开始独立判断，
你的思想才会慢慢成熟，
我之前看到有一些类似于教育学家吧，
他们会把人的认知成长简化成三个阶段，
我回望了一下自己的认知成长，
我发现确实也是在这三个阶段中，
慢慢成长起来的，
第一个阶段就是二元对立阶段，
我很小的时候，
最常问我妈的一件事情，
就是我们俩一起看电视，
我会问这个人好的还是坏的，
出来一个人我就这样问，
接着那个时候我们老看三国，
就比如说那个曹操出来了，
我就问我妈这个好的坏的，
我妈就跟我说，
哎呀打仗的事很难说对错的，
然后我对这个答案就非常不爽，
他回答完我就会觉得，
你这说了跟没说一样，
这什么答案吗，
我就不一不饶，
接下来电视上出现另外一个人，
我又问我妈这个好的坏的，
然后我妈就一直被这样问问烦了，
她就跟我说，
刘北是好的，曹操是坏的，
然后我就记住了，
哦刘北是好的，曹操是坏的，
我前几年又重看了一遍老三国，
我真的觉得，
确实你很难跟一个小孩子在解释，
为什么说，
你不能单纯地说这个人是好的，
这个人是坏的，
其实当我们很小的时候，
能快速地分出对错，
对我们来说是极其安全的，
如果你告诉我这个是坏人，
我就觉得哦这个是坏人，
那我离他远一点，
哦这个是好人，
我离他近一点，
就是在我们很小的时候，
我们需要极速地判断，
我们所处的这个世界，
我们周围的这些人是好坏，
所以我们才能判断，
我们接下来是怎么照顾自己，
因为你太小了嘛，
你没有能力保护自己，
所以你非常急迫地需要知道，
谁是安全的，
谁是不安全的，
如果是按照这个逻辑的话，
我就在想，
现在在网上所谓的二级馆的人，
所谓的一定要分个对错好坏的人，
是不是因为他就是弱小，
他就是害怕，
所以他一定要迅速地知道，
哪个是对的，
哪个是错的，
我要站在哪一边，
这样才能让他获得一种短暂的安全感。
然后当有一天，
我们慢慢长大了，
我们变得强壮了，
我们有能力保护自己了，
或者是，
当我们发现世界上不是非黑即白的，
你长大了，
你上学了，
你会发现这个说的有道理，
那个说的也有道理，
那么你就不会急迫地去分对和错，
那么你下面就进入了另外一个阶段，
这个阶段叫做相对主义阶段，
相对主义阶段是什么呢？
就是,
觉得一切都说的有道理，
每个人都有自己的道理，
共说共有理，
婆说婆有理，
什么都是对的，
这个阶段，
它的问题就在于，
你自己就没有什么稳定的东西，
你的内心，
你很容易被别人带跑，
就成了一个强投草，
今天别人说这个对，
你就觉得这个对，
这个有道理，
明天别人说那个对，
你就说那个也对，
那个也有道理，
我都支持，
我都理解，
都可以，
这个阶段看似是很包容的，
看似是很开放的，
但是你自己没有站立的位置，
既然你觉得什么都对，
什么都可以，
从任何一个角度都可以理解的话，
那么你自己吃什么意见呢？
你如何选择呢？
你是不是就像一个自行车，
它掉了链子，
踩那个踏板的时候，
那个踏板是极其灵活，
极其好奇的，
但是这辆自行车它不往前走的呀，
如果你觉得什么都是对的，
那么你选择相信什么呢？
你把这个阶段渡过去，
开始选择自己相信的东西，
那么你就进入了一个相对比较成熟的，
承担责任的时期。
在这个时期呢，
你面对很多的不确定性，
那么你就可以根据自己所知道的信息，
运用自己的逻辑，
做出自己的判断，
但是你做出自己的判断的同时，
不是一个封闭的状态，
你可以保持自己的灵活。
如果找到了新的论局，
或者是如果有了新的材料，
证明你观点其实是错的，
那么你也可以改变自己的立场。
重要的是有足够的东西来说服你。
如果简单的说一个人他认知成熟的过程，
大概就是这三个阶段，
这也是我们逐渐可以独立思考的一个过程。
其实我们在很早之前就接触过独立思考了，
在我们非常小的时候有一篇课文，
那篇课文叫做《两小而变日》，
我不知道大家还记不记得这个故事，
我跟大家讲一下这个故事是什么样的。
这个故事就是说，
孔子东游的路上看到两个小孩在那边辩论，
孔子就很好奇嘛，他就问两个小孩，
在辩论什么呢？
一个小孩说，
我认为太阳刚出来的时候离人近一点，
但到了中午的时候就离人远一点。
另外一个小孩说，
那我认为太阳刚出来的时候离人远一些，
中午的时候离人才近一点。
那他们有什么论据呢？
其中一个小孩说，
太阳刚出来的时候呢，
像车盖一样大，
但是到了中午呢，
他就小得跟一个盘子一样。
这不就是，
远者小而近者大乎，
离的远的东西小，离的近的东西大嘛。
另外一个小孩说，
太阳刚出来的时候，
天气还凉凉的，
等到中午的时候就像手伸近热水里一样热，
这不就是近的时候感觉到热，
而远的时候感觉到凉嘛。
然后孔子听了之后，
我觉得都有道理，
不知道如何判决，
他也不知道谁对谁错。
那两个小孩就笑着说，
淑为乳多之乎，
谁说你知道的多呢？
我觉得这个故事被特意记录下来，
就是因为它是一个很珍贵的小孩子，
在进行独立思考的一个过程。
我小时候看到这篇文章的时候，
我就觉得特别厉害。
这两个小孩他们都不迷信权威，
并且都觉得自己有理有据，
经过自己的思考，
所以他们对自己都非常有信心，
而且每个论据都非常充足。
所以即使他没有一个令人幸福的答案，
但是呢，
这场争辩，
他依然被保留了几千年，
然后被我们看到。
那我们在现在，
寻找答案如此简单的一个世界，
我们该如何培养独立思考能力呢？
我自己想了一些方法。
这些方法完全是出于我自己的个人经验，
它可能有很多疏漏，
它可能不那么正确。
如果大家也有自己培养独立思考能力的方法呢，
也可以写在评论区。
那么我先讲讲我的经验吧。
第一个就是我认为，
一定要给自己留出足够多的时间思考。
我回想起我人生中最爱思考的阶段，
一般都是大快的时间投入的时候。
比如说做选题，
可能会提前一个月你就知道自己要做什么选题。
我就会用这一个月的时间慢慢搜集资料，
慢慢研读，
长时间沉浸在这个选题当中。
当你长时间沉浸在一件事情上的时候，
你的思维就会对这件事格外的灵敏。
它就会发散到各处，
然后可能在某一天突然蹦出来一个有趣的想法。
你投入大量的时间做出来的选题，
肯定和你一周之内诉成的东西完全不一样。
好的东西一定是投入大量时间的，
好的思考也是。
有时候我就会去读一些作家呀，
哲学家的生平故事。
你就会发现，
思考者、创造者，
他们都有大量的时间用来搞创作。
我记得马尔克斯说，
他自己在写百年孤独的时候，
就把自己关在房间里面写了18个月，
几乎都没有出门。
他既不需要做家务，
也不需要操心家里面的事情，
所有东西都给他妻子包了。
所以他才有这么多的时间，
跨在自己身上，
写出百年孤独。
有时候我们就会说，
人们应该思考，
但是其实很多时候人们不是不思考，
而是没有时间思考。
我们生活过，
我们都知道一天下来，
能够用在思考上的大块的时间，
其实是非常少的，
因为我们有很多所遂的事情，
有时候是不得不回的消息，
有时候是不得不做的家务。
信息的话其实还可以免打扰，
你关了就好了，
给自己一片思考的时间。
但是地板脏了这件事，
就很难视而不见。
我现在长时间在家嘛，
我经常会想着东西，
想着东西就开始盯着桌子上的灰尘开始擦了。
所以有时候我就在想，
怪不得以前很多那种哲学家，
文学家都是贵族，
因为他们不需要自己打理生活。
他们有非常多的时间，
可以来发展自己的知识。
不过我觉得生活在现代的好处之一呢，
就是有无数的聪明人，
他愿意运用自己的聪明才智，
来解决这个世界的难题。
比如我们今天的赞助商科沃斯，
我从去年跟科沃斯合作完之后呢，
我就一直在用他们家的扫地机器人了。
我们家现在租的是两层的房子嘛，
越层的那种。
一楼就有科沃斯，
二楼就没有，
体感真的完全不同，
一楼每天就是清新爽爽的完全不用打理，
二楼呢，
就我每天需要用吸尘器在那边吸猫猫。
前阵子他们家新出了X12S Pro 吸地机器人。
我用下来最明显的感觉就是，
无论扫地还是托地都比之前更加细致了。
比如我一直很喜欢的零字喷容功能。
简单来说，
这个功能它就是专门用来对付中式厨房重油屋的。
大家都知道厨房的地板它其实很容易油腻腻的。
那么他们的机器人就会先喷一圈，
清洁液，
让油字、酱子先溶一溶，
再用干净的热滚筒，
一把滚过。
所以,
其实它就是在模拟我们平时擦地式，
先喷清洁液的逻辑。
这样拖完的地立刻就变得BlingBling的。
而且这一代新款有一个让我非常惊喜的功能。
在家的时候我特别喜欢光脚踩地板嘛，
但是又总是很担心地面上有细菌。
那X12S Pro,。
这次不光能把地托干净，
它还能做好地面消杀。
我现在隔几天就会打开消杀模式，
让它把厨房、客厅都喷洒一遍，
出出军，
弄完之后就可以大胆的光脚踩地板了。
作为一个有点懒，
但是又有接批的人来说真的非常方便。
我们前面一直在聊人需要独立思考嘛，
我觉得做产品其实也是一样的。
要不断地去想那些大家已经习惯了的麻烦，
是不是还有更好的解决办法。
科沃斯的品牌理念是，
创造无难事。
我自己的理解是，
用科技帮助大家把生活里那些反复消耗人的家务所事给接过去，
减少大家的难事。
所以他们一直在思考的其实都是很具体的事情。
比如厨房的油屋怎么清洁的更彻底啦，
家里的地板除了扫脱干净能不能顺手把厨金一起做啦。
最后这些思考全部都落在了X12S Pro上，
他又把我最近关于地面的烦恼全接管了，
让时间能真正的为我所用。
对我来说地面清洁一直是一间很好时间，
也很容易打断状态的事情。
虽然有时候主动做家务确实可以转换心情，
但是我想做和我不得不做其实还是两回事。
而且独立思考本身也需要一些完整的不被打断的时间，
你得有空把看到的信息慢慢消化，
再形成自己的判断。
所以我觉得现代科技很重要的一点，
就是让这些重复的，琐碎的事情变得简单。
哥沃斯通过不断思考，
持续利用新的技术解决我们生活中的具体麻烦，
剩下来的不只是做家务的时间，
也是把更多的时间还给我们自己，
去享受生活，发展知识。
如果你也想把这些琐碎交给哥沃斯，
给自己多留一点完整的时间，
可以点进胸口字中的连接查看相亲。
关于培养独立思考能力呢，
第一个就是你要留出大量的时间给自己去思考。
那么第二个我觉得就是大量的阅读，
可能有朋友觉得，
既然我独立思考了，
那我为什么还要看别的东西，
为什么我还要击取别人的思想。
其实我觉得大量阅读一定是对我们的思维是有好处的。
我们在阅读的时候，
也是在看别人是怎么思考的。
尤其是我们拿到的那本书，
有可能是一个人，一个很卓越的人，
他必生的思考结晶。
其实是在我们没有能力去读懂那些，
很卓越的人写的那些思想结晶的时候，
我们也能通过阅读去习的一些事情。
我就想起来，
我小时候其实是没有很多书读的嘛，
我最喜欢读的书就是，
我们学校里面会发一些课外阅读，
然后我就翻一遍翻一遍翻的很多，
那个书也都给翻卷了。
那个时候其实我有一段非常美好的时光，
大概是初中的时候。
那一段时间就是因为我们家的那条街上，
开了一家小小的书店。
那家书店不是那种大型的新华书店，
是一家还挺有意思的独立书店。
你想像在我们家那种和南小城的一个独立书店，
可想而知它的生意其实是不好的嘛。
我那个时候还是一个10岁出头，
11岁左右的一个小孩，
就经常去那个书店去读书。
他那个书店是有两层的，
一层是卖书的，
第二层是一个读书室。
你要想去那个读书室，
你其实是需要办会员的，
好像还挺贵的，
我就一直没有钱去办嘛，
就老去一楼站在那里读。
那个老板是一个年轻的大学生，
应该是一个刚毕业的大学生。
他看我老来，
后来他就大手一回说，
哎，算了，
你就去二楼读吧，
也不要你钱了。
那段时间我就读过了一个非常愉快的书架。
它里面有漫画，
有那种小人书，
有故事书，
有童话书，
我就一直在看。
看的过程中，
我觉得我学会了一种阅读方式，
就是这本书里面，
所有的字我都会看。
我在上小学的时候，
其实没这个意识的，
因为有老师上课的时候，
老是会说打开多少页，
我们看第几行，
就这样去讲了。
我在这种大量的课外阅读的过程中，
我学得了一种阴读禁读的读书方法。
有一天，
我们在初中的一节语文课上，
我们老师提出了一个问题，
那个问题就是，
针对我们当时正在学的一首诗，
那首诗是路由的梅花绝句好像是，
那个绝句的最后两句呢，
是这样的，
何方可画身千亿，
一树梅花一放翁。
当时我们老师就讲这句诗，
然后就问大家，
放翁是什么意思？
我们班同学一个个面面相学都不知道放翁是什么意思，
还有一个同学狙击手来说，
就是放牛的老翁，
显然不是嘛。
这句话其实你看字面意思是很好理解的。
何方可画身千亿，
就是哪种方法可以让我的肉身变成千亿个，
就是路由他想学会多重影分身，
然后呢一树梅花一放翁，
一树梅花很好理解，
就是一个梅花树嘛。
那么一放翁是什么意思？
大家都不知道。
我当时呢因为有了一个习惯，
就是课本上的字我都会去读，
所以我是知道的，
这个放翁的意思呢就是路由的字，
路由他也叫路放翁，
所以一树梅花一放翁的意思就是，
他希望每一棵梅花树钱都有一个自己。
但是我最后忘记我又没有举手回答了。
我在这里想说的就是，
其实你阅读的过程中你会习的一些东西，
未必是里面告诉你的知识而是一些习惯。
除了习得一些读书的方法呢，
我觉得大量阅读还有一个好处就是，
书嘛,
它代表着很多人自己的思想。
如果你没有去大量的阅读，
只读一类书，或者干脆就是不读书，
那么你的价值观，
你的想法其实是被周围的环境影响的。
那周围的影响可能是非常单一的，
如果你们处在相同的环境里面，
你们的想法可能会大体上有一点相向，
但是这种相向有可能就会扼杀你的独立思考能力。
一旦你有别的想法的时候，
你第一反应是，我是不是不可以这样想。
但如果你是一个大量阅读的人，
你读了一本书，你读了两本，读了三本，
读了四本，读了五本，
读了不同人写的很多本书，
书里面的观点也都是不一样的。
由于你知道人是可以有不同思想的，
人是可以有不同想法的。
一旦你知道了这件事情，
那么你其实是敢于有自己不一样的想法的。
那么接下来第三个我的经验是，
训练批判性思维。
批判性思维它其实是一门课程，
你在B站上可以搜到非常多的，
批判性思维的课程，
就是教你如何去思考，
如何去有逻辑的思考，
如何做出一些理性判断，
所以它不是一两句话可以说清楚的，
但是我觉得如果你想独立思考的话，
其实越早训练批判性思维，
越早接触这样的课程对你越好，
我记得我有一阵老师在B站上听一个，
统计大学的教授讲批判性思维，
他那个讲的怎么说呢？
很有意思吧，虽然粒子举的很多时候不太恰当，
而且他可能因为年龄的原因，
有一些发言也会让我们不是，
但是他在讲清楚这门课需要的技能的时候，
我确实会觉得，
那段时间我的思维变得非常敏捷，
我感觉自己整个人聪明了许多。
今年年初的时候，
我妈就跟我一起相处了三个月，
然后我有朋友就问我，
他就说那你们总吵架吗？
其实三个月我就跟我妈只吵了一次，
我很多朋友得知之后都很震惊，
你就觉得原来母女在一块还有三个月才吵一次架的。
但其实是这样的，
我妈年初跟我一起生活的时候，
因为他没有什么事情干嘛，
我就让他去看批判性思维课程，
因为那个课程他讲得非常通俗，
他举了大量的生活的例子，
可能这些例子有时候不那么恰当，
但是确实老少杰宜大家都能看懂，
然后我妈在听这门课的过程中，
我意识到他整个人变得平和了很多，
冷静了很多，
有时候还会运用他的理性思维。
我跟他之间就不再是我们两个情绪的在对话了，
我们竟然可以进行一些真正的沟通了。
所以我特别欣慰，
特别有意思，他讲故事的方式都变了，
以前他讲故事就是把这个故事讲完，
讲完就讲完就觉得哎呀，
这个人就是这样啊，
很小气啊，很尖草啊，很内傻啊之类的。
那段时间他讲故事的方式都变了，
他讲完故事之后他会跟我说，
这个人他之所以那么小气呢，
是因为他挣钱比较难，
他已经开始去推理背后的原因了，
而不只是看到表面了。
但是呢，
批判性思维这个事情就是要不断的在生活中去磨练，
就是要在事上磨练嘛，
你要不断的去培养这个能力。
我妈三个月之后她就回老家了，
然后离现在大概有半年左右吧。
最近我跟她视频通话的时候，
我感觉她又回到了原来的样子，
逻辑又变得没有那么清晰了，
在讲书一件事的时候也是情绪大过理性思考，
但我并不是想指责我妈，
我只是说，
培养这个能力它并不是意识的，
你就算习得了这个能力，
你可能几个月没有运用你就忘了，
你又重新变得混乱起来，
都是有可能的。
这门课因为我没有办法一一给大家讲它具体有什么内容，
但是我可以比较粗略的讲一下，
我认为批判性思维是什么样的，
就是首先批判性思维，
它肯定不是一个全盘接受的一个学习过程。
当我们看到一个东西，
我不是说这个东西拿到手里面就全然的相信了，
批判性思维这几个字看上去好像是很有攻击性，
好像说我要批判之类的，
但是我觉得批判性思维它并不带有这种攻击性，
反而它是一种非常理性的。
当一个事情发生的时候，
无论你是全盘接受就觉得这个对，
还是想的不想就直接这个错，
它俩都不是批判性思维，
那么什么是批判性思维呢？
就是当一件事发生的时候，
先静下来看看事情到底是怎么一回事。
这个不急着判断对错，
它停滞的、静滞的这一段时间，
就是一个很好的批判性思维的开始。
用一句比较土的话来说，
就是当一件事发生的时候，
我们经常会看到一些评论说，
让子弹飞一会儿。
我有时候特别喜欢看学者的采访，
就是因为他们在回答问题的时候，
不是急着回答这个问题是或者不是，
他们有时候会停几秒，
然后想一想再说，
说我猜你问这个问题，
你其实是想问什么什么什么，
那么我的回答是什么什么什么。
我觉得这个是一个很经典的思考后的一个答案，
而且它会让你感到特别清晰，
直接一针见血。
我觉得训练批判性思维最难的一点，
其实它的方法并不难，
你只要去学习你很容易能掌握，
但是它在实际运用中就没有那么简单，
因为它需要你承受不确定，
没有答案，
一切处于一种很混乱的状态，
它没有那么清晰，
你在一团迷雾里面，
有些时候你可以通过自己的努力自己的思考，
慢慢的将迷雾给拨清楚，
这样的话你看到的就是真实的世界，
而不是为了急着把迷雾赶走，
突然变换出来的一个也许是幻象的世界。
那么接下来第四个就是，
大胆的跟人讨论自己的观点，
如果你不把自己的观点说出来，
那么这个观点它其实就没有人反驳，
因此你就不知道自己的观点是否站得住脚，
它是否有漏洞，
所以如果你大胆的说出自己的想法，
哪怕它可能有一点蠢，
但是一旦你说出来，
你就有机会把它发展得更完整，
或者是你直接换了一个观点也有可能，
而且其实你在给别人叙述你自己的观点的时候，
你也会发现你在脑子里以为它已经非常完备了，
但其实你说出来的时候，
它是没有那么完备的，
甚至有时候你在脑子里觉得它绝对是一个很好的观点，
但是当你说出来那一刻，
你可能立马意识到它其实是一个根本站不住脚的东西，
而且如果它是一个很好的东西，
你分享给你的朋友，
你们俩一起讨论这个观点，
如果它跟你一样，
它可能会引入新的经验来佐证你这个观点，
如果它跟你不一样，
它可能会在不一样的地方跟你反驳，
它一旦反驳了，
你就会发现自己的这些观点它可能有运行不顺畅的部分，
那你就可以把它修正，
比如说我之前一直有一个观点，
但是这个观点我怕太不严谨，
我就一直没有跟别人说，
然后直到前一段时间我跟我朋友视频，
然后我们就聊到，
我最近发现了一个事情，
就是说明珠这个东西，
我们都知道它是经过时代的大浪逃杀，
最后出来的一些很好的东西，
但是我会发现，
即使是大浪逃杀，
它也有自己的高潮期和低潮期，
就比如说我最近就发现，
像悲惨世界呀，
巴黎圣母院这样的明珠，
它已经不怎么流行了，
因为悲惨世界里面它是塑造了一个非常接近圣人的人，
叫做然阿让，
这样的人，这样的大圣人，
这样的一个心灵极其美好，
极其纯粹的好人，
可能在这个时代已经没有那么流行了，
因为大家不相信世界上还有这样的圣人，
然后我就说，
可能是因为它这个形象在我们现在这个时代，
它有一点过时了，
但是这个过时并不是说它永久的过时了，
可能在下一个时代，
可能10年后，20年后，30年后某一个时期，
它又流行了，
然后我朋友就继续问，
那它在什么样的时候会流行呢？
这个问题我之前就没有思考过，
我就在想，
也许是在一些让人心潮澎湃的革命般的时代，
或者是一个大家对浪漫主义还怀有期待的，
然后整个社会的风气是昂扬向上的时候，
也许它又会流行了，
就比如说我们之前讲包法离夫人吗？
我觉得包法离夫人在现代流行，
就是因为它讲的是一个平庸的世界，
我们现在处于这样的一个时代，
那么很多年前，
我们在解放战争的时候很显然，
包法离这样的数据不会流行，
因为它太是一个适合平庸时代的作品，
它能在平庸的时代里面垫破人性的UOA之处，
然后在庸场的世界里奔发出更大的力量，
但是在一个相对大时代的时期，
它很可能就会被轰轰裂裂的东西给淹没，
然后我们就就此这样聊，
然后它就问世界上有没有一个作品，
它无论什么时候都流行，
无论是我们处在浪漫的时代，
还是理性偏现实的一个时代呢？
我突然就冒出来了，
我就觉得那红楼梦肯定是了，
红楼梦自问世以来，
它一直就是一个很受欢迎的作品，
然后我就在想为什么呢？
因为它里面什么都有，
你想看浪漫的纯粹的美好的东西里面有，
你想看现实的批判愁恶的东西，
它里面也有，
甚至你是一个美食家，
你对吃的感兴趣里面还有，
所有人都可以在里面看到自己想看到的东西，
所以这本书就是会一直活下去，
所以我想说的就是，
可能你在跟别人讨论的时候，
它只是一个很小很小的一个想法，
也许你们在讨论中它就会发展的越来越多，
越来越有趣，
当然我刚才说的这些举的这些例子，
很有可能我的观点是完全错误的，
只是我那个朋友没有指出来，
或者是他跟我的想法是一样的，
如果大家听了之后觉得你这个观点不对，
被惨事件还是流行的，
那你也可以写下自己的观点，
然后我看了之后我再选择我要不要修正，
还是我依然认为自己是对的，
所以大胆的跟人讨论自己的观点，
你的思考能力就是会变得越来越强的，
我觉得我人生中开始向别人说自己的观点，
真的就是这几年的事情，
我显然会觉得我这几年比我原来的时光要思考的深入的多，
就是因为我敢于表达自己的观点了，
而且这些观点很多时候是要受不到别人的质疑的，
然后因为有可能会受到质疑，
所以我在说的时候我一定会想得非常清楚，
然后我就会不得不去思考的更深，
在我大学或者是我刚毕业的时候我根本不会思考那么深，
因为我不觉得谁会修正我，谁会质疑我，
谁会觉得我这个不对，
因为我也不对别人说我自己的观点，
所以我非常推荐大家大胆的跟别人讨论自己的观点，
即使它可能有点愚蠢，不要害怕，
只有不断的跟别人讨论，
你才有可能让它去发展。
那最后一个我的经验就是练习书写，
它可以让你肆意奔跑的思维变得更有条理起来，
因为你只要塑书文字，
你一定是要清晰的书里的，
因为你不书里的话你文字是不知道该怎么写的，
你也不知道你该运用什么样的词你说的对不对，
而且你写下来的时候真的很容易看出来破绽在哪里，
比如说我会去听一些播客，
我听的觉得讲的都对啊，
因为它是一个语言性质的，
你可能只是听，
但是你把文字搞下来你会发现哇这是什么呀，
我自己有时候也是，
我自己有时候录播客录了很久，
然后我把它转文字之后决定要删哪些，
我就会发现天呐我在说的是什么呀你，
用文字一看你就会非常清晰的知道，
这一大段是废话，
这一大段说的完全不对，
每次我把我自己的语音转成文字稿，
我都会有一种很清晰的感觉，
这就是文字的好处，
所以如果你想要训练独立思考能力的话，
最有效最快速的一个训练就是书写练习，
很多朋友不知道自己要写什么，
我有时候书写练习就是我会把一个问题当成题目，
然后我试着去回答这个问题，
可能我自己光在这边想它可能思维非常发散，
但是你在写的时候你的思维一定是慢慢聚笼的，
然后把这个问题标在上面，
先写第一条我想的是什么第二条想的是什么第三条第四条第五条，
你可能写得出来非常多答案，
你想到哪里然后你就把它写在哪里，
等你写完了之后你停一会再去看，
然后你就可以画掉其中很多，
你觉得其实没有必要写的东西，
然后你可以再写一遍，
这个时候你再写就顺畅的多，
你的思维也就清晰的多，
也会在书写中发现自己其实是有立场的，
你其实不是说没有自己的思考，
如果你不太喜欢写呢，
那还有一个办法就是你画思维图，
你画你是怎么想的，
用竖状的也好啊，
用一大串从上到下的这种小小的一个。
铺铺流一样的东西去想也好啊，
就是你把它弄到笔尖上，
那在这一期我们主要聊的就是培养独立思考能力，
可能也就会有朋友说，
哎，那我现在听你在思考，
我跟着你的思考，
那我是不是也是思考外包的一种，
我觉得不是，
因为思考外包就是你直接知道答案，
思考这个过程是省略的，
但是我们今天在这期播客的时候，
我们是有这个思考过程的，
你只是在听一下别人是怎么思考，
而不是真正的思考外包，
我今天说的东西你可能完全不认同，
你也不相信，
或者是你思考过后之后发现你也是这样想的，
那么你都是思考过了，
今天我们说了那么多，
我不知道大家在实际生活中会怎么实践呢，
我觉得第一步呢，
就是先给自己创造一个适合思考的环境，
这也是为什么我觉得科沃斯的创造无难，
是跟今天的这个话题很契合，
我们当然不可能创造一个人生从此没有任何难题的世界，
甚至恰恰相反，
人这一生最重要的很多问题，
本来就是没有标准答案的，
我要成为一个什么样的人，
我要相信什么，
什么东西对我来说才是真正重要的，
这些问题最后可能都得我们自己去想，
而科技真正能做的，
就是把那些已经有办法解决的，
重复的索遂的难题处理掉，
让机器去解决地上的难题，
把人的时间留给那些真正值得我们思考的难题，
最后再次感谢科沃斯机器人对本期节目的支持，
拜拜!